noah manoir bonjour et merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation sur rt france
est ce que vous en savez plus sur les
circonstances de ce qui ressemble à un
contrôle routier qui qui donc a mal
tourné non j'en sais pas plus parce
qu'en fait je pense qu'il n'est pas
utile d'aller chercher des informations
en dehors du cadre des enquêtes c'est à
dire que on a des images qui nous
permette d'avoir en tout cas des
éléments d'analysé sur la situation à
l'instant t c'est-à-dire l'instant où
les fonctionnaires de police ont fait
usage de leurs armes à feu et je pense
qu'il faut pas aller au delà c'est à
dire que là on a des versions qui ce
concept est en réalité c'est à la
justice de faire justement la bonne part
des choses entre la réalité et les
versions des uns et des autres donc moi
ce que je peux dire pour être utile à la
collectivité c'est à dire pour permettre
aux gens de réfléchir par eux-mêmes
c'est dans un premier temps déjà lancé
un appel au calme auprès de la jeunesse
et en même temps les inciter à respecter
la loi c'est à dire a obtempéré aux
injonctions de la police c'est que quand
vous avez un barrage routier qui vous
demande de vous arrêter d'obtempérer bon
ben si vous risquez une contravention
parce que la plupart du temps quand les
refus d'obtempérer c'est parce qu'il ya
un défaut d'assurance un défaut de
permis ou parfois une emprise de l'état
alcoolique un au volant du bon bah c'est
que quand on fait le ratio entre le
risque de d'être verbalisé avec une
contravention et les risques de se faire
tirer dessus je pense qu'il vaut mieux
s'arrêter obtempéré voilà après on peut
toujours contester les contraventions
etc c'est une autre affaire
ensuite au plan politique je veux dire
que bon on a deux éléments moi qui me
trouble c'est dans un premier temps
c'est que si effectivement on avait fait
voter la loi sécurité globale ce qui a
été le cas et qu'elles avaient été mises
en applications telles que le voulait
ministère acteurs on n'aurait pas eu
accès à ces images et donc on aurait eu
finalement pour seules versions la
version a priori mensongère des
fonctionnaires de police donc là on a eu
effectivement diffusion sur les réseaux
sociaux de ces images et ça nous permet
de nous faire une autre opinion parce
que faut savoir qu'après les faits on a
eu tout un tas de dépêches d'articles
etc qui nous précisait que au moment des
tirs au moment des deux de l'usaj de
larmes administrative que les policiers
étaient en situation de menace vitale
c'est à dire que les été en danger que
la voiture s'apprêtait à aller percuter
donc là aussi que le conducteur aurait
fait marche arrière et percuté un des
fonctionnaires de police qui aurait
ensuite fait usage de son arme
voilà tout à fait alors après il faut
savoir que les larmes administrative à
s'utilise uniquement dans le cadre de la
légitime défense donc la légitime
défense c'est quoi ces trois critères
c'est là le premier une atteinte donc
une atteinte vital c'est quelque chose
qui mettrait les policiers en danger de
mort le deuxième c'est justement la
proportionnalité c'est à dire qu'il faut
que les policiers soient réellement en
danger de mort pour pouvoir atteindre
leur cible de façon létale est la
troisième chose c'est la simultanéité
c'est à dire qu'il faut le faire au
moment opportun si la menace est expiré
au moment où les policiers peuvent faire
usage de leur master qu'il faut pas
tirer ensuite alors dans cette enquête
les éléments troublant c'est que le
conducteur quand bien même allez on va
dire qu'il était en tort et que les âges
de larmes étaient caractérisés c'est
qu'il n'était pas seul dans la voiture à
côté de lui il y avait une passagère qui
elle est innocente de ce qui s'est passé
elle n'est pas au volant elle n'est pas
aux commandes du véhicule elle a été
touchée elle a été victime d'un tir
c'est à d'un tir de 9 mm elle a été
atteinte dans le doubs c'est à dire au
niveau mots au niveau des organes vitaux
puisque son pronostic vital était engagé
juste après les faits donc il appartient
aux policiers il avait connaissance de
la présence de cette passagère
puisqu'ils ont contrôlé le véhicule qui
s'est arrêtée on voit même un policier
mettre la tête dans l'habitacle donc il
ne pouvait pas les policiers
délibérément engagé
le moindre risque quand dallas vie de
cette passagère puisque le conducteur
lui effectivement peu risqué sa propre
vie mais les policiers n'ont pas le
droit de risquer la vie de cette
passagère qui est en dehors de toute
responsabilité dont vous voyez il ya des
choses après
dans cette affaire au premier une forme
de confusion ambiante puisque la
préfecture de police s'est empressé de
faire parler vous poser une autre
question pourquoi pourquoi selon vous la
bac a voulu contrôler ce véhicule c'est
le rôle de la bête de d'effectuer des
contrôles routiers où il y avait des
soupçons portés sur ce véhicule en
particulier
je pense que c'était un contrôle de
routine je savais en fait pour le cadre
légal qui permet de contrôler un
véhicule c'est à priori la commission
d'une infraction ou la détection va dire
d'une entrave au code de la route c'est
que si la voiture a un peu une veilleuse
grillé ou quoi que ce soit c'est un
motif suffisant pour déclencher un
contrôle routier donc aussi elle grille
un feu rouge ou quoi que ce soit un stop
on peut déclencher un contrôle routier
donc ça c'est pas le problème je pense
que les policiers sont à même de se
justifier sur les raisons qui ont poussé
qui les ont poussés à contrôler les
véhicules et d'ailleurs le conducteur
n'est pas innocent de tous puisqu'il a à
priori refusé d'obtempérer mais la vraie
question qui va se poser dans les débats
de justice c'est de savoir si
effectivement le à
l'attitude des policiers à savoir l'
usage de leurs armes à feu étaient
justifiées au moment précis où ils l'ont
fait ou pas et les images de vidéos qui
amateurs qui ont été diffusées sur les
réseaux sociaux a priori alors selon moi
et ça n'engage que moi ne démontre pas
l'existence d'une atteinte et morte elle
potentiellement mortelle est immédiate
au moment où on a fait usage de leurs
armes à feu donc la famille de cette
femme qui se trouvait à bord du véhicule
va certainement déposer plainte et donc
demander des comptes aux policiers parce
que tu as écouté entre laisser partir le
véhicule gros convoqué le conducteur
ultérieurement le l'intercepter avec des
moyens administratifs autre que la
remarque que puisque les policiers de la
bac sont dotés de ce qu'on appelle les
stop stick donc c'est ce sont des herses
mobiles qui permettent de crever les
pneus des véhicules et de l'empêcher
justement de continuer sa progression
donc ça serait plus être envisagée vous
voyez donc c'est une affaire qui va qui
va faire débat
alors on n'a pas besoin résultat de ces
deux enquête de l'igpn et de la police
judiciaire malheureusement on manque de
temps mais merci à vous anwar d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur cette
affaire je vous rappelle que vous êtes
ancien fonctionnaire du renseignement
intérieur et chroniqueur aux médias tv
et merci à vous